[Applause]
[Music]
Hello everyone. I'm
Harada, the leader of the Tekken project.
Right away, today is the first time we're
using this actual Tekken 8 machine, and it's
full of visuals, and
we'd
like to explain the new gameplay mechanics.
I think Tekken 8 has such elements, but I want you to
see it, so
let's go right away.  I think it's a lot,
but
once again, this theme, of course, the game
system, but the
effects, the
stage production, and all the
elements that appear in this game are the
keywords of the theme.  I'm using the word "aggressive."
This is also the
first time I'm going to explain to you all about the game system, so
please keep this keyword in mind.  I
want to provide the best exhilaration of the series for both the viewer and the viewer, with the battle system and advanced visual expression, as I said earlier, including the effects and the camera work and production.  That
's where the
director will explain. There are
three major points that we're
aiming for in terms of gameplay in battle.  We're
aiming for a battle system that allows players to have an easy-to-find battle or a climax-like experience.  I
'd like to introduce the 4, but this time I'd like to
introduce these 4. Rage system and
recoverable gauge heat system
Controller style
First, I will
introduce the changes to the existing system.  As
you all know, the rage
system has been in place since the age of 6, but there have been some changes this time.  It will
automatically activate when your HP drops below a certain level, and it will
become a physical strength bar, and a
red aura will appear on your character,
increasing your attack power and
allowing you to hit a big move called Rage Earth.  It
's a mechanism that increases the damage as it decreases.
So, it's
not necessarily the correct answer to use Reiji Arts, but you
can also take strategies like keeping a good player in a Rage state and fighting with your moves while your attack power is up, so let's
play a little Rage from now on.  If you're watching
Tekken 7, you can definitely experience this place, so please play around with it.  If you add
more and more, it
will become complicated, so I will organize it once and the
register drive itself is
gone.  I wonder if there's an
easier way to do it, specifically what kind of command it is.
Basically, it's
common to all characters.  You
can activate rage arts with a single button, right? Even in 7, I've
made it so that it can be
activated with a single button,
but this time it's
inherited.
There was a little in the tag, but the
system is new again, so please explain.
It remains as a recoverable
part, and if you block a specific big move, it remains as a recoverable part, so the
heat system and exposure in battle are pretty
important systems.It's
similar to the red gauge in the Tekken tag series.  A
characteristic feature is that there is no recovery over time.
We thought about how to
recover physical strength by performing more aggressive actions.  If you do
n't have enough adrenaline, you'll get
out, and if you take damage, you'll recover.
It's common to want to recover a little and
rebuild the system, so back
dash cancel back dash
If you don't gain an advantage even if you're
passive
Then, while looking closely at the actual machine, I would like to
give a little more detailed explanation.
When you block a big move, it
will remain in the health display as a white recovery gauge like this.This white gauge itself
doesn't disappear over time, right
?
However, with certain attacks, the
attacking side can erase or erase the opponent's recoverable gauge part, and
now, if
you hit a little lower level, for example, it
feels like the damage will come in this way.  The
side with the recovery overwork gauge remaining will not
recover if it is stopped, so it will
recover by reaching out and launching an attack.
Yes, that's the core system of this time,
but I would like to explain the heat system in detail.
But I don't think I understood the whole picture at all, so
today I would
like to delve deeper into that.  It's a
bonus time that
can be attacked for a certain period of time.  There
is one way to enter the heat state.  Even if you
set this R1 button,
heat can be activated at any time with a single button.
Then the timer under the health gauge
will decrease, and if you don't do anything, the
heat state
will end in 10 seconds, but it's relatively long, isn't it?
10 seconds It's basically 10 seconds, but in fact,
this heat timer phenomenon
can be stopped by itself.  I think you'll
understand, but if you
keep attacking, you'll be able to continue the battle while maintaining your state.
First, there are two conditions for activating Heat.
Each
character has multiple things set, and if you
hit the opponent like this, you
can approach the opponent while running and apply pressure to create an overwhelmingly advantageous development before launching an attack.
Each character doesn't have a single activation technique. Mainly, there
are about 5 on average.  So,
first of all, beginners,
or rather, people who want to start from this time,
should first learn these five tricks.
Tekken has a lot of different techniques
, but in order to make it easier to understand which technique to start with, I
set several of the character's characteristic techniques for the string activation techniques.  It was
put on something like an instrumental card. First of all, you should memorize
this skill.  I've
become able to fight Well, above all,
King has a lot of great moves, and even
in a fighting game, he's got a Guinness World record.
That's why I learned the heat bonito technique first.
First of all, learning the heat activation
technique is the
shortcut to improving Tekken.  But let me explain a little more
fine details.  With
this attack, even if the opponent
hits the opponent or blocks it, I
have an advantageous frame, so I would
say that it is easy to continue that attack.  It
can also be used as a part of , so for example, you can use it to levitate your opponent and hit them with this
heat
burst.  I
think there's a bit of concern that the attack might come out and create a gap, but actually, you
can cancel the heat burst itself and do nothing,
so
if you want to activate it at a distance, do that.
Don't worry, you can also use Cancel to enter in the
Heat state.
Well, yes, you
can also do aerial combos like Tekken 6. It's
new to look at, but it feels
nostalgic.
However,
there are about 5 heat activation moves that are set for each character.The
feature of this is that if you hit the opponent, the
character will close in on the opponent and launch an attack in a
frame that is significantly advantageous.  It's
quite easy to continue as it is because it's a characteristic trick and technique. It's
a little
different depending on the opponent's reaction to being hit, but
the point that the chance or climax is here is easy to understand with this heat activation technique.
Also, it's an
easy-to-understand point, so if this comes out, the world will definitely continue.  The
bonus time during the attack is called the
heat system,
and in this fixed period of strengthening time, you
can create a starting point for your tactical offense.  There
are three main things you can do with it.
One is that you can use actions only during heat.  It
remains in the opponent's physical strength as a possible gauge, and
it also has features such as strengthening the character's individuality and characteristics, so I'll explain in detail from
now on.  Can you
please explain a bit what
this chain-
like 8 is?
There are two sexual actions that can be performed during heat.
One
is a powerful technique like heat smash, which can only be performed during this heat timer.  There
is one that can be activated by consuming a marker and can be activated by consuming energy.The other is a
heat dash, which
allows you to cancel a
heat activation move and dash.
This
smash is such a powerful technique that it's
easy to understand, but I'm wondering
if you could explain a little more about where this dash should be used.  You
can cancel the attack to reduce the free frames of that guard, and
when it hits, you
can cancel the hit activation move and connect it to an aerial combo.
I know, but when you
enter the heat state, you usually
get hits like this, but by performing a heat dash, you
can change the hits and land an aerial combo, so
it's a pretty important system.  Well, I
figured out something about it,
but it looked like the amount of heat energy was different depending on how it was activated.  You
can get one Heat Energy You
can do a Heat Smash Heat Dash even if you only have one.  As you can see from the
heat initial move that you have to hit, you
can get 2 heat energy.
Then, perform two heat dashes
Cancel
Then, it
will probably be used properly in the bargaining.
Well, if you use it alone, you can also use it for this so-called
lazy drive.  It's a
powerful attack, so
if you want to take damage or
set it up, I
think you can get a big return by actively aiming for a hit smash.  I
think that the player's individuality really comes out in the fact that you can push it all the way to the wall at once, and the variety of
ways to
handle it will really come out.
Depending on the person, there are
people who are the type to take it all the way to the end, and there are
people who hit a heat smash the moment they get into a heat.
There are some people who are disappointing that they don't show it like it's been there for a
long time.  If you
look at it, you'll understand,
but the recovery gauge will
remain
as much as the opponent guards.
There is
no such thing, so the opponent's recovery gauge will be left, or rather, it will
remain,
so if the opponent attacks back aggressively, as I said earlier, it will recover, but it will only be on the defensive.
Well, that
's kind of what it feels like, so I'm in a hurry
because I've cut
quite a lot.I think the effects of the heat system during activation are common and character-specific, but
please explain a little more about that.
At the beginning, I explained the direction of the battle,
but I still want to
develop the character's individuality and characteristics during the heat.
By holding, you can
get a guard ufo habeyu technique only during heat It
destroys the opponent's guard, or rather,
it has a guard break effect, so you can overwhelm while taking more advantageous frames
On the contrary, low is a speed character and requires a
lot of work.  There are a lot of Rush characters, and this time he
has a nunchaku, so his
attacks with the
nunchaku are
greatly strengthened.  It has the effect of strengthening the nunchaka, and if you
hit a nunchaku attack only during heat, it has the characteristic that the reaction that normally knocks you down suddenly
changes to the one that starts an aerial combo.  I've
gotten a lot stronger. I've
gotten Mr. Hara to use it again, so King
is a professional wrestler, and this time I'm pushing for muscles, so
during that heat, a
new running action has been added,
but that new action
is in a power crash state.  If you take the opponent's attack and
rush in at all, you can rush in with the feeling that it doesn't matter and force you to
make two choices.  I
feel like I'm
looking forward to it.  It's
said that you'll
be able to do a lot of things during the heat, and you'll
have a variety of attacks, so it's
a lot of fun.
Of course,
it's at a disadvantage when you're guarding, but
from the point of view of the person being attacked, is there a
point where you can counterattack so well?
That kind of thing has
n't changed, so I'm going to have to guard it and get past it and put my
hand in where I can properly insert it.
Rush has also been strengthened, making it
easier to use as an interrupt.
Crash
is quite a point if it's strengthened, but as a
system of Park Rush, it's like this.
Well, you're
prepared to be hit by force, but the
big difference from Tekken 7 is
that the damage is a recoverable gauge.
Yes, if you attack again, it will come back,
so it will be easier to interrupt.
Actions are also effective, so you can use your hand to turn back, or you
can guard as before and back dash sideways to see
what's going on.  That's
nice, why is the defending side temporarily at a
disadvantage?
And this time, it seems that the style of playing the cat controller is
a little
new, so please explain that.  Of
course, it's
possible now, but another thing is that we've
prepared a special style that combines the simple combo assist function that was in Tekken 7.
What is this?  In other words,
each button has a recommended move for that character, and
just by pressing the button, you can play the attack like an action game.
Well, it's not just that, right?
Right now,
nothing has been released, so it's an arcade-style
operation,
so you can create the feeling you like.
Press L1 and this is a special style.  It
's a user interface, and it's
like aerial kelp power crash, lower attack, hit burst, and
attacks are assigned to each button.
Combos are made by repeatedly hitting this triangle
button, so it will
connect so that an aerial combo can be determined.  It was supposed to be
assigned to a button, and if you did this in order from left to right,
this time it would work, but this time you can
connect to this with a single button, and you can also select
different types of
combos.
After that, if you hit the whole circle again, it's
different.
Yes, this aerial combo changes depending on the character's state.
Hey, hey, hey, it's
amazing that anyone can do this, isn't it?
There is a feature that the character decides with various variations of aerial combos that are the real
thrill of Tekken.  I guess
that's what you mean. If you have
something that can be used as the basis for bargaining
in your attack set, and you want to break the opponent's guard,
try hitting the round button first, or if your opponent
seems to be making a move, use the park
crash cross button.  Let's cut in.
When you start attacking yourself,
use the square button's heat activation technique and aim for this
aerial combo's triangle button to
break the damage more and more.  There
was a system like a simple assignment technique, was
n't there?
But I don't know which
one to use, and I do
n't know how to use the timer, so
this guide button will
appear.  It's
like I'm going to practice with a style where I can
switch and open myself.  It's a
feature,
but it seems like it can be
used fairly well even by middle-advanced
players.
For example, depending on the state, the aerial combo will
switch, so if you're in heat mode and at
0:00, you'll be
able to do quite technical combos, so I'll
show you a little bit of that now.  You
say there's a mode, but
story mode
or other modes like that, for example, everyone is curious about
that online battle Online
ranking match Or a normal
waiting for players,
of course I wonder if this can be used
Basically, I made it
so that you can control the character skillfully and coolly, so
it's a very useful function when you control various characters like in story mode, and I
made it so that you can enjoy it even if you use it only in battle.  Whether
it's a vs mode or an online battle, there are no
particular usage restrictions.You can
enjoy various characters, and
people with various skills
can play in a wide variety of modes.
If you can play like that, you
might be able to get to a certain level in tournaments, I
think.  You
'll probably hit a wall from that line, but it's
certainly a good system in terms of boosting up to that point, is
n't it?
I explained to everyone that
this development is actually
about to start, but it
looks like it
will take a long time.  We've packed a lot of things into the game and are
adjusting it, and we're
developing it with a really aggressive stance.
So I hope you
look forward to it, and since the development is still
going on, the scene of Tekken 7 is
still going on, so
if you enjoy Property 7, I think it will be a source of encouragement for us as well.
Thank you very much,
so I would like to proceed with this video today Thank you very much
Thank you very much
[Music]